femmes 1 point c'est toujours pareil il
n'y a personne de sérieux dans cet hymne
je suis sûr que quatre lumières oublié
de faire la commission et puis même s'il
n'a fait quand je lui n'a pas de servins
elle doit faire autre chose très bien
aux léonard je peux rentrer évidemment
quelques questions si tu le dis petit
mois tu as l'air toujours de très bonne
humeur tournant je n'aime pas s'attendre
kobo tu exagères ya combien de temps que
tu as demandé à casimir de venir me
chercher à diminuer bon et comment bien
fait il de temps pour aller jusqu'aux
jardins environ cinq minutes alors cinq
minutes pour casimir pour aller
jusqu'aux jardins plus cinq minutes pour
toi pour venir du jardin jusqu'à ici ça
fait dix minutes je sais je sais je suis
très très forte que mais quand même tu
aurais pu courrier au bac ou deux si
c'était ça que tu voulais me dire moi je
peux repartir à maman je sais j'ai
mauvais caractère c'est vrai mais tu
pourrais être un peu indulgente avec moi
d'accord alors qu'est ce que tu dis oui
les bouviers j'ai réalisé ton rêve mon
rêve c'est gentil mais qu'est ce que
c'est mon rêve tlf royan celui de ta
chanson tuchan avait beaucoup d'un coup
là avec beaucoup de douceur léonard
léonard ce n'est pas juste du tout tout
ça n'a pas d'importance là n'est pas la
surprise alors qu'ils ne deviennent pas
pas du tout as tu n'es pas astucieuse
j'ai fait pour toi un tableau andrieu
oui ouais mais c'est formidable
alors tu l'a fait avec beaucoup de
couleurs et beaucoup de douceur
alors pour les couleurs je crois qu'on
que ça va la douceur tu sais pour moi
c'était plus difficile
quel parti a été choisi sans que tout le
monde quand les voyons jardins jardin
mais qui n'est jamais sorti tu as mal
comment l'as tu dessines et je les veux
une fois et j'ai une mémoire fantastique
tu crois que tu n'a oublié aucun détail
bien sûr toi tu les as tout n'est ce pas
alors
oui oui tout ça
tu penses départ regarde voilà le
tableau
est bien je n'en reviens pas et c'est
seulement de trouver un détail qui ne
soit pas à sa place et bien justement
j'étais en train de chercher un détail
qui soit à sa place quoi quoi mais tu
dis ça parce que parce que tu es un os x
non pas du tout léonard jeta sur écoute
nous allons appeler françois et les
enfants oui ils diront qu'ils donnent
u21 réseau wacs est afin d'accroître à
fait d'accord tout de suite
allons franchement oui il faudrait que
tu viens de tout de suite ici oui avec
les enfants surtout
merci merci
[Musique]
venez vite les enfants de de witte
léonard a besoin de 8 à yann arnoux
voilà on a fait vite enfin nantes
n'assistons pas s'il te plait je t'ai
fait venir pour prouver un jury qu'elle
se trompe et comment derniers tableaux
et la reproduction exacte du jardin 2011
fondement
bon on va regarder cette pré julie
montrent leur le tableau voilà leurs
rayons les enfants qu'en pensez vous
c'est tout à fait ça
c'est pas tout à fait exact quand est ce
qu'on va faire je vais retirer les
éléments et vous allez m'aider à les
remettre à l'endroit un long terme à la
cage à poule
devant
l'arbre et le soleil
voilà on commence par le soleil alors le
soleil tout place au soleil à votre ami
dans le fond au milieu la
voilà un peu plus un peu plus comme ça
comme ça c'est exact
très bien maintenant
l'arbre le plus bel art de l'île aux
enfants c'est plus grand à côté du
soleil
je suis par ici voilà racing
j'irai dernier mon fils lui
a le dont on se sert beaucoup de bon
sens est la région la plus peuplée au
voilà
voilà le kiosque de julie
comme ça qui le mettrait
au là c'est bon là je dis non oui mais
c'est la charge mais aussi pour la medal
au caucus qui n'est pas
à gauche
c'est comme ça ça pas très loin du
casque de julie voilà expulsé en fait la
cage à poules
bernard conseil oui effectivement il
vient devant l'arc en ciel
et ben voilà il y en a regarde là je
suis prêt la cedh examine chaque fois
faudra observer davantage
écoute léonard je suis ravi d'avoir
raison mais je suis désolé que tu sois
malheureux côté c'est vous qui devrez
gnac malheureux vous voulez qu'un
tableau soit une rampe production n 5 de
la vérité et vous oubliez complètement
l'imagination d'un artiste
[Musique]